we played roulette oh yeah yeah
well um
I watched this uh watch this dude go
from probably a hundred bucks to 600.
I love that I just like how how are you
actually good at roulette that's crazy
to me yeah I love it too because it's
like the stack just grows so big because
they dish it out in fives yeah
so all of a sudden he's just you know oh
he hit like a little starfish man yeah
he had one on top and then one on each
Corner oh my God yeah hit that number
yeah that's sick nailed it
and then uh it wasn't a really animated
guy
and but when he hit that I I just said
dude
and he smashed my knuckles I don't think
he's like yeah yeah it came out he was
like [__]
yeah you're feeling that [__] dude
meanwhile I'm losing money and I just
kept asking the guy can I shove my money
in the hole
and I said can I throw up in there after
you take it all can I just I'm sure he
loved that oh he was geeking I'm sure he
was chuckling me was he really yeah like
dealers hate that [__] oh no he was in
good spirits and then the the so I lost
and then the Pit Boss came over and she
goes no you have to double down on black
that's how you get it back and I go oh
yeah like I'm gonna [__] trust you
and she goes you're gonna wish you dead
and then yeah but can I puke in that
hole Yeah
can I [__] and cry in that hole what is
in that hole yeah let me in there let me
in the hole I want to be inside be
inside that hole it's a new face listen
to me
Pit Boss
let me see what's in the hole
Yeah that that's a new fetish man being
shoved inside a roulette table
and then just chips getting poured on
you put me in the hole put me in the
hole in a little chat yeah I'm a five
dollar kid
I want to be a little chip I want to be
in the hole scoop me yeah man I'm going
to Vegas so I'm gonna do
three more opening or four more opening
sets in the next two months let's go and
then I'm going in between weekends for a
friend's birthday so I'm going five
times you're gonna in the next two
months so get ready to move for three
months get ready to move yeah I know I'm
you know checking out some real estate
out there already yeah yeah
making sure I'm prepped there's plenty
of it
you can live pretty much anywhere there
dude yeah I'm thinking about living on
the strip in the Aria
Planet Hollywood yeah all the worst one
I used to love flying in Hollywood and I
went there I don't know how recently and
I said man this place like literally
stinks does it it's kind of stinky not
the traditional stink yeah it's just
it's pretty worn yeah because it's like
dead center so if you gotta foot traffic
yeah Vegas is getting old I mean not
that it I mean did you have you seen
that Tick Tock about like the worst uh
Vegas hotels like what the Rio looks
like nowadays oh nah
I'm sure I we we took a we took a gander
through the Excalibur oh yeah like a
couple months ago holy [__]
my memories as a child were extinguished
that's a bummer I said oh man this place
looks like I could push it over
what's happening yeah I'm pretty sure
like all that whole like first wave of
hotels they're all like plagued with bed
bugs and deserted now so you playing
excess
yeah four in a row
Yeah well yeah excess
uh Encore Beach Club at night yeah all
the times let me come through one of
those and perform a song
over like
uh Earl Sweatshirt type beat
just so weird
set yeah
oh
I told these [__] you better back up
before I pack the back in the back of
the back of them yeah
Vegas let's go
I used to boof Benadryl and Sudafed in
the back of the school bus
I punched my English teacher in the nuts
what happened to the house music
house music yeah just start freestyling
they're like whoa this song's
Interactive
just picking up what conversations in
the crowd yeah just one song or or you
come on
and uh I give you the mic and you could
be like
you are listening to the most racist DJ
in all of Las Vegas if you're here right
now you're here supporting
the white race exclusively and you hate
others and you are xenophobic
you are not here for anything other than
the white race
Make Some Noise Tick Tock Clips
afterwards yeah I accidentally went to
the most racist DJ set
when you go to excess and it's a KKK
meeting
just a [__] burning cross in the
middle of the crowd like whoa
this shit's kind of bad the best
gambling did I tell you about the horse
machine oh we watched the little toy
horses that's the best one you didn't
know yes that's my favorite okay dude I
cannot lose on that machine I swear to
God it prints money I want it's a cheat
code I wanted to go in on that but I
felt is it was there one I've walked
past a couple oh okay but I I you know I
was thinking I was better than people of
like elbow Elena be like these [__]
look at these chumps oh what no the
whole time I wanna of course I want to
be in yeah yeah I'm like looking at him
like look at it's a toy like I wanna I
Wanna Be it's sick it's like a carnival
game were the horse is magnetic or were
they on a track it's this oh yeah yeah
they're on a uh they're on a track it's
this yeah magnetic I guess oh what yeah
hold on
it's super sick but you I mean you
mostly watch it on the screen because on
the screen there's like a real animation
but uh
so you basically bet on who's gonna come
one and two yeah
and it's like a grid so you can bet on
it's so fun and you can basically play
the whole board
so that you never lose yeah yeah no yeah
but oh and there's an instant replay the
odds change every time so it'll be like
occasionally you know it'll be like uh
the odds of four and one coming in first
in place right first and second place
are like for fifty thousand so you put a
dollar on that okay it's like the bonus
yeah I mean that's just real horse yeah
you're just doing real horse race
bidding so yeah is that how it works
yeah
it's all the same yeah so there's like
never bet the ponies
I I've bet like the Kentucky Derby one
time through a friend and that was the
time that
it was the only time in history where
they like recalled the the winning
decision because they found they they
found out that they were cheating or
whatever and I won like a couple Grand
or something and I was in Vegas wait how
are they cheating can you look it up
three years ago or something you win a
couple Grand and I were like oh my God
we won the Kentucky Derby holy [__] and
then and then found out later that
afternoon that it got taken back yeah
doping Scandal only time it's ever
happened I'm pretty sure the winner
failed a post-race drug test
oh it's like who gives a [__] it pissed
off course of course they're on dope the
horse tested P for EPO no they're not
what they're not of course on dope
come on steroids
they're all pumped full of yeah you know
you know the ponies are on Trend man
yeah dude yeah they got a trend cough
yeah damn that's what gave it away yeah
yeah the horse just Falls over
he's got a trunk off
what year was this
uh 2021 yeah
betamethasone an anti-inflammatory that
is used to treat joint pain in horses
though allowed in some states Kentucky
bars any presence of the drug on race
day wow
such a shame man
it's like they didn't even think about
all the people that won money you know
yeah they didn't even consider that they
didn't even think about all the people
who worked hard to [__] gamble gamble
yeah just like no one yeah yeah no no
there's research involved
cash don't [__] undermine the hard
work we do no there's there is for the
Kentucky Derby that is true I I don't
want to turn this into the gambling
episode
which it seems to be it's 30. oh no dude
people want to see evolve our content uh
news flash people
we've done everything there is to do on
this [__] website yeah
reactive videos you're doing that like a
thousand times yeah yeah uh what and
we're and at this point we're
desperately trying to get a stake deal
yeah yeah yeah make music we've done
that already yeah yeah what's next um
filming from our iPhones of us gambling
at slot machines what's up down 19 500
yeah yeah and the content is unedited
it's hours long and it's just this
yo
we're here
what's up so 45 minutes ago we hit a
stupendous win stupendous win kind of
still riding that energy haven't had a
lot of traction since then but I really
feel it's coming back yes I'm gonna go
walk in a circle yep because that seems
to work yep around the Cinderella
machine I'm gonna go do a figure eight
around that and I'm gonna pull my pants
down and rub my butt on the
on the uh the rich little piggies
machine you know just to feel like a
pig's ass and then we're gonna light it
up we're gonna throw five grand in there
and then just
all right
seemed to like when I did this before
yeah so you can brushed up against it
accidentally and we hit so you can see
the screen now and here off away we go
all right we are down 19 500
don't [__] show me this man those
pigs they I want to [__] eat them
those Rich Little Piggies I wanna like
yeah I want to like cut a check for
[__] squeeze them my whole net worth
and shove it in their hole
[Laughter]
um show us the pig hole I've been gamble
what I was gonna say is I've been
betting on sports a lot um like getting
into like yesterday I was betting on
like wait over under for certain players
yes keep going who's the guy that nut
tapped LeBron Dylan oh Dylan Brooks yeah
can you under on him
yeah
damn it I thought you're gonna tell me
you could bet on like sack Taps
probability of tabs you just hit it it's
like I'm gonna bet Dylan Brooks no but I
did I [__] bet on the Ryan Garcia
fight that there'd be a knock down in
the first four rounds and I hit oh my it
was like plus 270 or something the odds
okay